Huli and castro meanwhile claims that
heroic armed civilians are fictional as
fictional as his presidential campaign
more guns are not the answer more guns
don't make us safer this idea that a
good guy with a gun is gonna stop a get
a bad guy with a gun it doesn't work
that way well it seemed to work that way
in in Texas yesterday Ryan Kleckner is
an attorney and former Army Ranger and
he joins us now Ryan just on the sniper
side of you when you look at the
matching firepower here the distance how
would you rate what mr. Wilson did in
his church yesterday a plus I mean where
do I start except to say thank God for
mr. Wilson and his sig p210 handgun and
his practicing out at the range for him
be able to make that one shot and save
all of those lives well let me let me
put you the Joe Biden point because Joe
Biden's point seems to be the fellas
like him named need armed security
details he as his Secret Service detail
I believe he swims naked in front of
them most mornings which is not
something I'd want to see first thing if
I were a Secret Service agent but that
he needs he needs armed security and
everybody else can do without and can
just call 9-1-1 you're right this is
exactly why we have the Second Amendment
so that we can defend ourselves against
those that wish to do us harm and to to
talk about how great Governor Abbott was
for passing this law which he is and he
was but it bothers me that we even have
to celebrate the fact that he gate
passed a law that gave them the right to
carry guns in church
no guys our constitutional rights belong
to us before the government the
government doesn't give us the right to
carry in church it is so sad to me that
we have to have a law in Texas that
allowed them to exercise a fundamental
right told to defend themselves in
church I mean if we look at the anti-gun
errs Joe Biden he's wrong he was dead
if he had his way there would be a lot
more people dead in that church or we
have some anti Gunners like Sharon Watts
who says that it was only be happen
because it was allowed to happen by
Governor Abbott who allowed guns in
church criminals aren't allowed to do
anything with laws well I've talked
about this before that the very
definition of a criminal is they don't
obey laws no law allowed that bad guy to
walk into a church and kill people
it's sad that we had to have a law to
allow them to defend against that
there's a line that the Homeland
Security use if you see something say
something but in fact a lot of our
political leaders keep telling us
there's actually nothing to see that
we're being irrational when we're scared
of people in this case a fella walks
into a church he's he's wearing a wig
he's wearing a false beard and somebody
did see something and reacted
immediately is that really the way Wall
gonna have to be in the future no not
necessarily but I'm glad they did
something see I have a problem with to
see something say something I'm glad
these guys did something you know the
police are 15 minutes away when seconds
count they're heroes I'm glad we have
them but we're responsible for our own
safety until they get there and this
whole statistical argument I have seen
this come out of the woodwork since the
shooting because the anti Gunners went
oops again the bad guy was stopped by a
good guy with a gun we're wrong how do
we attack now Oh will argue statistics
this is so rare you pro-gun people are
crazy to worry about this we can't have
it both ways
it's either so rare and it's never going
to happen therefore we don't need guns
to defend ourselves or it's an epidemic
and they need to take guns away yeah
arguing both sides doesn't make sense
and there's no Police Department on the
planet that can get there in six seconds
which is the time that that mr. Wilson
took to it exactly right Ryan thank you
very much for that meanwhile in